doktor martin karsten ist arzt hier in
berlin und er wird die menschen heute
hier in der hauptstadt impfen und er ist
uns jetzt auch zugeschaltet guten morgen
herr dr kassen wie geht es ihnen heute
an diesem tag was geht in ihnen heute
vor das ganz fantastisch ist und ich
glaube auch was sie eben in ihrem
weitere auch erwähnt dass das einzige um
die pandemie zu bekennen zum und ich
glaube auch man muss den leuten
vertrauen aufbauen
wenn man sich die studie über die
impfung anguckt ich glaube es gab keine
impfung die so wenig nebeneffekte hatte
und es ist ja kommt ja quasi placebo
gleich und wenn man das sich anguckt und
weiß was das für eine tolle wirkung hat
diese 95 prozent ihr wirklich erwiesen
sind bei diesem impfstoff dann muss man
sagen also sich impfen gehen und ich
würde auch sagen nicht immer zu sehr vor
ich glaube auch die öffentlichkeit ist
zu sehr in details eingebunden worden
derlei versteht es ja nicht ich bin
kinderarzt ich impfe soviel jeden fall
kein mensch fragt mich gut an tetanus
impfstoff hergestellt
keiner fragt also genau nach und
interessierte die menschen und es ist
sehr schwer nachvollziehbar
und ich glaube auch hier wurde sehr viel
geredet und jetzt muss man sagen nach
vorne schauen
wir haben einen impfstoff der wirklich
in großen studien es wurde nie so viele
leute in im spiel vorher untersucht als
der neue impfstoff bekommen ist der so
wenig nebeneffekte hatte das sind
wirklich nur nebeneffekte wie einem
kleinen effekt gleich kommt und das ist
ja auch normal das will man ja auch ein
zeichen dass die impfung angeht
und da glaube ich kann man vertrauen zu
haben und man immer nur aufrufen sich
impfen zu lassen
also vertrauen in die impfung wenig
nebenwirkungen hätte der kasse läuft das
denn heute bei ihnen abkommen heute bei
ihnen menschen in die praxis oder wo und
wie impfen sie genau ich habe auch in
einem mobilen impfzentrum das sind diese
mobilen impfzentrum also man raus man
fährt quasi in die altenheim ist ein
team zusammengestellt das ist ein
bundeswehrsoldat der 1 war sie die
patienten denn auch noch dorthin bringt
da ist ein schwester dabei die den
impfstoff aufzieht und der arzt ist ja
in erster linie dabei die aufklärung zu
machen und natürlich darauf zu achten
dass es eben keine zeit effektiv
14 was natürlich sein kann was auch
schon mal vorgekommen ist sind eben
seltener allergien aber das ist ja auch
womit man umgehen kann
also ich glaube jeder arzt kann mit
einer allergischen reaktion umgehen und
das ist dann eben auch eine ganz ganz
wichtige sache
wissen sie denn schon wo sie heute
impfen und wem sie als ersten info
das erfährt man jetzt gleich also man
geht und man fährt dann in einen in ein
zentrum in berlin das ist der flughafen
tegel und dort aus geht es denn in die
verschiedenen einmal da wird man dann
hin geführt wo er ist wie viel das ist
das weiß ich auch noch nicht
aber was ich gehört habe glaube ich
wissen dass alles immer arzt wenn wir
elf tagen grippeimpfung haben
da haben wir eine super logistik da wird
also da werden sich ja viel viel mehr
leute geld werden als man heute im hier
sich auch die aufklärung die gespräche
wichtig es gibt ja auch zahlen schon von
dem ersten heim was im harz vorgezogen
wurde
da war ja auch die impfbereitschaft
nicht so riesen hoch also nicht dass
alle unbedingt die impfung wollt die sie
bekommen können aber ich glaube ist das
arztgespräch und dann muss man als
achter das vertrauen aufbauen und hoffe
das gelingt ein
es ist natürlich schwerer bei patient
immer nicht kennt als bei den eigenen
patienten in der praxis aber es ist ja
auch so spannend und ich glaube da ist
erfahre und wichtig und dass man sicher
damit umgeht und auch die fragen der
patienten beantworten kann
sie haben die allergien angesprochen die
ihn wirklich ganz ganz wenigen
einzelfällen großbritannien aufgetreten
sind es waren ja weniger als zehn fälle
überhaupt und zwei die wirklich nur
nennenswert waren aber in solchen fällen
wie lange muss man als patientin unter
aufsicht eines arztes oder einer
krankenschwester bleiben um klar zu
haben da passiert nichts oder ist nichts
passiert das sind 15 bis 30 minuten und
das ist dann gegeben also eine gute
reaktion und wirklich akut und com kommt
dramatisch es dreht sich jetzt nicht um
die kleine rötung am arm und
gelegentlich was auch bandenbildung was
wir nennen diese tk ria wenn eine
richtig systemische nebenwirkung und das
erkennt den art schnell und da hat man
natürlich medikamente dabei wo man es
sofort behandeln kann
und auch hier denke ich ganz wichtig die
anderen leser werden patienten sagen ich
bin hoch allergisch
dann kann man muss man eben anders
wachsam sein als ein einer sagt ich noch
nie wirklich zu tun hat und wenn man
sich
die in diesen ganzen zulassungsstudien
die daten anguckt gerade die älteren
person hat mir viel viel noch weniger
neben berg und noch weniger zeit effekte
also ich glaube gerade den älteren
menschen kann man beruhigt sagen gebt
die können ganz beruhigt die impfung
annehmen auch fieberreaktion überhaupt
systemische reaktion hatten da noch
seltener auf als bei den jüngeren
und die jüngeren zu impfen steht ja
zurzeit noch gar nicht zur debatte